jessica ortigue et travaille dans son
jardin et dans des conditions précaires
assistantes de vie auprès de personnes
âgées
elle a dû se reconvertir après une chute
elle a fait de sa passion sa nouvelle
activité professionnelle elle a emprunté
deux fois 1000 euros auprès de l'adie
pour se lancer
ils m'ont croyez à un crédit est donc un
prêt d'honneur qui m'a aidé donc pour
pouvoir constituer mon stock en fait
et puis pour pouvoir avoir une petite
base pour démarrer correctement quoi
mais ne vous ont pas que donner de
l'argent
non effectivement on est très bon
accompagnement donc c'est vrai qu'ils
sont très présents au moindre souci on
peut les appeler sont toujours là pour
nous aiguiller pour le conseiller
prochaine étape pour jessica ortigue et
trouver un atelier où une maison avec
une pièce qu'elle pourra consacrer à son
activité
[Musique]
jean-marc films l'un s'est installé dans
cette péniche propriété du grand belfort
il y a cinq ans lui en cuisine son
épouse dominique en salle depuis deux
salariés les ont rejoint cet été ça
s'est bien passé avec cette année a été
exceptionnelle je pense déjà votre le
temps façon jamais cru contrefaits
autant il a emprunté à la 10 10 mille
euros la somme maximale pour acheter du
matériel et pour payer trois mois de
loyer en caution je suis allé à die
présenté mon projet c'est vrai que tout
de suite
il avait l'air emballé il n'y a pas les
mêmes relations entre l'a10 et moi
qu'entre une banque et moi moi je
préfère aider une association comme l'a
dit parce que voilà ça j'y crois parce
que c'est des gens qui piquent qu'ils
sont humains
la banque elle est pas humaine et des
l'a dit oui car jean marc film là à
reverser 5 % de son prêt soit 500 euros
à l'adie pour de futurs emprunteurs mais
tous les emprunteurs remboursent il
vraiment leurs prêts oui alors
heureusement sinon on n'existerait plus
depuis longtemps
on fait des financements adaptés c'est à
dire qu'on va travailler avec la
personne le projet donc on travaille le
besoin de financement par rapport aux 6
à sa situation personnelle à sa capacité
de remboursement
c'est pour ça qu'on arrive à récupérer
ben les fonds qu on fait emprunté est de
toute façon on est dans l'obligation de
les récupérer parce que nous mêmes nous
remboursons les banques nous prêtent de
l'argent selon l'adie les emprunteurs
sont souvent chômeurs et son diplôme et
trois ans après leurs prêts 84% d'entre
eux ont un emploi
ça y est